-Very nice to have you here
in studio.
We wanted to give you a taste of
what it's like
to be in an arena again.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you. It feels good.
-It feels good.
-I missed it.
I missed it.
-You missed that.
You had your first
preseason game.
You didn't play.
-Did not.
-But you guys played against
the Lakers.
So it's officially starting up
again.
How are you feeling?
-I feel great.
It was crazy to come out.
We had fans during the playoffs,
but it still felt different.
You know, like the benches
are all spread apart,
our seats on the benches
were spread apart.
Now they're just like --
Two months later they're like,
"Nah, okay, we'll just get
everybody back together.
Let's sell those tickets
next to the bench."
So it was just good to be out
there again, you know?
-As a veteran, how important is
preseason basketball to you?
-It's -- It's necessary.
-Okay.
-But, you know, playing a game
that doesn't count is --
it's always a little weird,
but it's just nice to, like --
after doing training camp
and scrimmaging
against your teammates
the whole time,
it's nice to play against
other people.
-You joined the Nets halfway
through last season.
You had a chance then to sign
a contract anywhere.
You chose to stay in New York.
I know you spent
a lot of time here
and it's your first time
playing here.
How have you enjoyed it so far?
-It was great, man.
It was nice to --
You know, I had that stint
last year
and really got to know
the organization.
You never really know until you
actually spend time there,
and top to bottom, everybody in
the organization is incredible,
from the owners down to the
players, the staff, everything.
So that was the reason.
Also, the fans here in New York
are unbelievable.
So it was a no-brainer for me.
-So it's kind of crazy the level
of talent and fame on this team.
Kyrie, Durant, Harden, yourself.
You're a vet,
as we've established,
but you were, you know,
new to this team.
Do they haze you at all?
Is there any like,
"you're the new guy,"
or do they kind of --
do you have the respect that
comes with being someone who's
been a multi-time All-Star?
-No, since it was like --
I've been in the NBA
for 12 years now.
I actually got to skip
the hazing part.
We keep that for the rookies.
But it's light. It's fun.
It's like carry
a Dora the Explorer backpack.
That's what I had to do.
-When you were a rookie
you had to carry
a Dora the Explorer backpack?
-Everywhere we went,
I carried a pink
Dora the Explorer backpack
into the arena,
hotels, everywhere.
So that's the type of stuff
we do.
-I would imagine --
I'm surprised there was one
that would even fit
on your back.
-Well, you undo the strap
all the way.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And you throw it on
one shoulder,
and I would always just put
one shoe in there.
-Alright. Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
I imagine that's about all
you could fit.
One thing I also want to ask
about being a 12-year vet,
is you get to know the referees.
And you sort of have
a reputation for someone
who's going to talk
a little trash to the refs.
But there are times we've seen
you actually laugh at
what a ref has said back to you.
What's happening
in those moments?
-My relationship with the refs
has -- It's been a rocky one.
A few years back
I had a camp for kids,
and I had to ref
one of the kids' games.
And I was doing so bad
that even the 7-year-olds
were yelling at me.
And that's when I realized
I should be easier on the refs.
Now, it's just like, I play
kind of two games a night,
where I'm playing basketball
but I'm also trying to make
the meanest ref laugh.
So I'm just working out
ref-based puns before the game.
You know, watching film
but also going over some jokes.
But it's -- I don't know.
They have such a hard job.
Such a hard job.
No matter what,
somebody is going to hate you.
Half of the audience
is going to hate you.
-Yeah, and I would imagine, too,
again, having to basically
police people
who are beloved and famous
is a really tough job to have.
-It can't be easy, and the best
ones are the ones who are like,
if they mess up, they're like,
"I messed up that one."
Because it's all happening
so fast,
and they're just trying
their best,
and if any of you refs
are watching, I'm so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I will try to do better this
season, but we all mess up.
-I like that you -- you realized
that reffing a camp
because I went -- after I left,
I went and I hosted "SNL,"
and hosting "SNL,"
I immediately had --
I felt like I wanted to go back
to all of the hosts
that I had worked with over
the years and apologize to them
because anytime a host didn't
want to do something
that we wrote for them,
I thought, "You don't know."
And then I want back and I'm
like, "Oh, no, they knew."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's basically
my relationship
with the refs in a nutshell.
-You guys get to tip off
against the Bucks,
the world champs.
Does it make it
a little more exciting?
I mean, obviously
it's a long season,
and you can't get
too high or low,
I would imagine,
for specific games.
But does opening night have
an extra element of excitement
when you do something like that?
-Yeah, it is.
Opening night is always just fun
just because it's the start
of a new season.
You don't know where you're
going to go.
Also, playing
the defending champions,
it kind of sucks
'cause you have to sit there
and watch them get their rings.
So there's that aspect,
but they deserved it.
Grueling season last season
and came out on top,
so it'll be fun.
-I mean, you mentioned everybody
being back.
Does it seems like,
for the first time in two years,
"Oh, this is going to be
the kind of basketball season
that I was used to
before the pandemic hit"?
-I hope so. Yeah.
I mean, the playoffs
felt pretty normal.
But like I said,
there were still a few things.
Like last night's game in L.A.
felt very normal,
besides being a preseason game.
So hopefully we're back
and people get vaccinated
and come to games.